this is the ftth council meeting in
munich when I'm talking to Graham Finney
of heavy reading Graham how do you see
the market at the moment for FTTH across
Europe what I see is an incredibly
fragmented market you have markets where
you know everything's going relatively
well in some cases extremely well as in
Russia which is by far the largest
market by number of installed lines
there are other markets which is doing
quite well like Netherlands way we see
we've seen quite a lot of deployment
some deployment in Spain other markets
where almost nothing has happened and
it's what's unusual about the European
market is its fragmentation the number
of different players and then were
people involved and one aspect of that
difference is the fact that incumbents
are not the dominant providers in terms
of lines installed compared to other
parts of the world so you know one of
the biggest questions in my mind trying
to analyze the market and it's a very
difficult market to analyze its
determining when it is that the big
incumbents in Europe will make the Great
Leap Forward where they're deploying far
more lines you know on this sort of
industrial scale activating lined on an
industrial scale and having the
confidence that that is worth doing
because that just hasn't happened yet
and it's really the fact that the factor
above all which has held things back now
it's not the only one you know I mean
the municipal providers in some
countries who had very ambitious plans
in certain cases have not fulfilled
those plans either it's turned out to be
a lot more difficult than they expected
either from a deployment point of view
or they've got the marketing or wrong so
there's quite a lot of issues in Europe
where things have not gone to plan but
at the same time there are now enough
positive examples out there for people
to learn lessons and look at the really
successful providers like all tea box in
Norway and say how did they do it there
must be some lessons for us and this is
the way forward and are you are you
confident that we'll get there there's
the economic situation there are the
technical issues but do you think
ultimately you know we'll catch up with
us some other regions in
world well I mean the economic situation
is is a is a factor which is held things
back there are new options of course for
the incumbents you know in terms of the
regeneration or the revitalization of
dsl and copy technologies particularly
through vectoring technologies which
allow them to extend the life of copper
and might in some cases lead them to
delay ftch further now having to settle
of that ftth is the endgame they're
bound to get there in the end the
question is when and that's going to
vary enormously from one country to
another so we'll see okay we'll look
forward to it thanks for talking to us
thank you ftth connects the world when
are you getting connected ladies and
gentlemen welcome to Munich for the
ninth edition of the ftth conference
creating a brighter future